hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach now we're going down this
elevator it may or may not be the right
place that I need to go but I know I
know what awaits me the [ __ ] is that oh
oh yeah that's right okay so I
completely remember these things down
here are blinded they can't actually see
me but they can smell me and they can
hear me
okay that's just smoke don't need to
worry about that hey don't mind me Oh
like music down here but it okay
everything's fine don't worry about it
um hi
whoa ha ha
you're cutie oh boy kill me
Oh cute he's gonna kill me oh no okay
it's fine
oh boy okay
all right so they patrol this downstairs
area and I don't think it's going to be
as easy as walking down here because I
think they're going to loop I don't
quite remember
oh I don't quite remember well I don't
know what that is
what is that oh it's night vision well
that'd be a smart idea
oh hi ha ha ha ha ha ha ha I don't think
it sees me but I need to move no one
forgot the bad human boys as oh they can
mimic they can mimic they can mimic
people I forgot about that okay all
right you're fine
you can skedaddle on by I'll be here
receding this
are you you good hi okay so he it he
they if that thing they just need to his
all group on by and that's totally fun
they Mississippi is particularly scary
cuz they mimic the things that they hear
and I I don't know if it's by some
psychic connection but it's meant to
lure whatever creature it is and I don't
know if they're intelligent to the point
where they could actually know that it's
people calling out to them so I don't
think that's it it's gonna make another
loop and I should be okay it decides to
turn around and then be cool too
yeah I don't think it has to any other
intelligence besides just mimicry so the
objective here is to go through this
place to try to find the other the other
oh no I'm out of breath oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh [ __ ] me okay
alright
I don't know why it didn't go for me
right down in there I don't know why I
don't know why I think it's gonna come
down this way Oh
yep it's gonna come down this way okay
so I just need to sneak yet mimics the
last thing that the UH wha but oh god oh
god
Oh put on the fricken you gasp whoa why
are we are we not we're not moving
why are we not moving
there we go okay all right okay all
right
so where are we is the big question so
we owe
what is this I've never seen this before
there's blood there but I don't know if
that's oh hi
[ __ ] god damn it hi you sack of [ __ ]
okay so I've never actually seen this
before so there's gonna be a new
experience for me if I'm ready for it I
didn't know this was just like here you
know Oh femme fatale oh I don't want to
look at him whatever it is I want to
look at it until I say all right we
saved now we can die a horrible horrible
death what are you I don't know this one
I really really don't know this one
[Music]
there's no button here not that I would
want to go in there anyway oh you have a
friend don't [ __ ] help hey oh oh oh
oh it's open now oh I don't know what
this is is the word shadow puppet show
in the world
oh I don't like all hey hey hi okay
alrighty then oh oh okay that's my spine
yeah that's my point I need that all
right there goes my brain it's not okay
[ __ ] what oh look oh and see p2o5
cycle seems to have resumed its normal
course after the anomalies observed
during redacted the body of subject p9 3
4 1 was discovered inside the chamber
the subject exhibits signs of blunt
force trauma typical for personnel who
entered the chamber when the lights are
off
okay that didn't go very well for me let
me actually read what this says there's
something strange going on here the
cycle seems to have sped up
significantly one of the horn figures
has already appeared in it's currently
having dinner with her so who is she
there's no NCP documentation to go along
with this so it's kind of just like let
me just see if I can watch the full
cycle you know from here because I don't
know what this is all about like I left
it it's SCP 205 in case you want to read
up on it on your own but I've never ever
seen this before in my life stop that
can I just enjoy the goddamn show here
because I'm go hi I guess you're going
to be there by suppose okay so there's a
horn figure and then the door opens and
I ain't going to go in the room ain't
gonna go in the room well the doors not
open anymore so I guess my opportunity
has gone hi oh oh and another member of
the party Oh
[Music]
I don't like this oh I don't like this
and I want to I want to go or leave okay
so I'm gonna just guess that if I go in
there again it's going to be nothing but
death and I'm not gonna be privy to that
can i okay all right so you all have fun
they're doing whatever that is
Oh was a new oh that's new oh oh did you
just punch her now that's just spelling
out my fate of what's gonna happen to me
if I go down there but the bad thing is
now I don't have a way to go back oh boy
oh well you know I'm just gonna lock
that in there let's forget about that
I'm gonna go back down because the only
way I can go is back down who's no point
the only thing on the other side of this
was another SVP and frankly I'm not
happy I went down there huh I'm not
happy I saw Amy go back flip you dippy
dude okay here we go back into the mist
of hell so there was other branching
paths down here
[Music]
Oh else is going I've never seen the
rest of this mmm they're not Oh whole
section can you pump it why why why why
why didn't that work
yeah fighting you're right there why
don't you work Oh like that
oh the storage area stall oh yeah you
are our start it's just somebody else oh
why are you just why are you just in I
thought I lost you for a moment there oh
there you are
I just got to get back now huh I think I
might be able to sprint through there
with just my gas mask I don't know where
it is
oh no worries okay I can I don't need
that what is this what is that
there's nothing what is that there oh
okay I think we are fine I think we are
fine okay all right we did it
whoa oh I don't feel good about that I
don't feel good about this at all okay
but either way we made it down into the
elevator of hell and we're back up so we
still need to find where the door
control is I think now it must be in one
of the unexplored areas that I was in I
was in like the other containment areas
so I'm gonna find that in the next
episode I'm all out of time for this one
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
[Music]